[Music]
thanks very much and yeah thanks
everyone for the chance to talk today
just to introduce ourselves a little bit
more I'm Sam this is Nick
we're both data scientists at uber in
the Amsterdam office so Bret she has a
fairly large engineering team in
Amsterdam focused on building payments
products for our global products and we
work on that and in particular we work
on modeling and experimentation to
understand how those products affect our
users behavior and those users can be
drivers eaters riders and the other
people on our platforms what we're going
to talk about today is what we do a
dooba when a be testing is not possible
so that is when we can't test the
results the impact of a product by
randomizing people into treatment and
control and because we are typically
working in a marketplace context so a
marketplace of riders and drivers and in
addition when we're talking about eats a
marketplace of riders and of eaters and
couriers and restaurants this is very
often the case that we can't just do a
simple AP test so we'll talk about some
cases where that happens we'll talk
about some different possible
alternatives that we do use or in
principle could use and then we'll focus
in particular on synthetic control at
uber so synthetic control is a method
that's used in industry quite widely
much more broadly than than just the
river alone the examples we'll focus on
will be specifically on the model and
the Python package developed by our
marketplace team at uber but we won't go
into great detail about these specifics
of a package this will be more of a
high-level overview so I hope is that if
you are new to a/b testing in your new
to alternatives to a/b testing you'll
come away with a overview of the
different possible approaches and how
they've been used to dooba
and then if you are already familiar
with these methods you'll come away with
a new take on on how another company is
using them and so now Nick will talk
about a case where this comes up a bit
thanks Sam
so as our motivating example I will talk
about about cash trips at uber and some
experimentation there so we haven't
always accepted cash at Hoover we
started off just a stuff in credit cards
and now it's actually
part of the magic that was part of the
pitch that you just get out and don't
have to pay or deal with it but then
when we invested heavily in Latin
America and India and markets like that
where there's not a lot of credit cards
it became important for us to accept
cash so that we could allow everyone the
chance to use uber like transportation
as reliable as running water everywhere
for everyone and so cash allows us to
operate in cities we wouldn't otherwise
be able to but it does come with some
problems for example change if your trip
is 17 euros and you only have a twenty
what happens the drivers have to carry
change maybe they ran out of change
maybe the riders don't have the exact
fare and so that that can get messy
sometimes they'll even stop go to an ATM
or go to a convenience store to make
change and you know it just it's it can
become difficult another difficulty is
how do you bird reverse pay over its
service fee for matching them with
riders and providing them with trips
normally if you have a cash trip the
driver will just take home all of the
cash strip all that fare and then on
their next credit card trip
uber will just take a little bit more so
that the driver can pay the service for
that previous trip but if almost all the
trips are cash then the driver actually
starts 200 burr money which is hard
because sometimes the driver has to do
something like go to a convenience store
and wire money to Cooper which takes
them off the road and it's just it's
just hard on the marketplace it's hard
on the driver and so so yeah there
definitely some problems here so because
some drivers don't like cash trips we
built a feature to tell them on every
request whether the trip is cash or not
so that they can accept it or decline it
as they choose you can see here in the
screenshot there's a little box here
that says cash for the trip is cash and
it says nothing if the trip is credit
car trip so say we wanted to do an a/b
test here on this feature and we wanted
to look at metrics like how does this
impact trip accept rates or how does
this impact the amount of unpaid service
fees that drivers Oh uber which is a
function of cash ships now for those are
not familiar and a/b tests is
essentially a randomized control trial
where you randomly the random is very
important split users into different
groups and you treat one group and you
leave the other group as business as
usual or control and then you come you
performance a physical test at the end
so if I was to do an a/b test here let's
say I had launched in a given City and I
would randomly assign half my drivers to
treatment and half to control and so
control users would which they would not
see this this indicator at all one way
or the other and the treatment drivers I
would tell them if the trip is cash and
then this would be blank if the trip is
credit card the problem here is an a/b
test doesn't actually work in this way
because of what you might call spillover
effects no and and an a/b test or
randomized controlled trial is only
valid if what I do to one user does not
affect another user and in this case the
treatment I give to one user spills over
to effect the other user and let me let
me tell you what I mean by that so it
turns out that drivers actually
preferred cash trips a lot and so when
we told drivers which trips were cash
let's say that they accept a higher
volume of cash chips and decline more
car trips and so in that case they would
have more cash chips per driver in the
treatment group but those car trips they
have to go somewhere right and because
they're still in the same market so you
can see in this chart here in the top
chart here's what the control looks like
with no experiment right with the dotted
line is the intervention but in the
bottom chart you can see that this is
say cash trips per driver when you show
the treatment group whether their cash
ships are not then they take more cash
trips because they know about it but the
control group actually takes less cash
trips than they would have otherwise
so my effect here is spilling over
because they're in the same marketplace
and so if someone requests a credit card
trip that can bounce around from driver
to driver until it eventually lands in a
treatment driver who wants a credit card
trick or a control driver who doesn't
know and so normally with an a/b test
you'll look at say the the difference in
sample means to do your statistical test
so that would be the difference between
the green line and the blue line but
that would actually overstate our
affect substantially here what you would
really want is the difference between
the Green Line and the white line but I
don't observe the white line because
there has been this spillover effect so
an a/b test is not going to work here so
let's think about some other things that
we could do just kind of as a thought
experiment whether you could do is just
before and after in theory you just roll
it out to everyone in the city see what
happened before and then see what
happened after the problem with this is
you don't have a control group so it's
actually not science and this is not
really a valid testing strategy because
the outside world actually affects your
users and therefore your metrics a lot
more than your product changes too often
and so if there was at the same time I
real this out there was like a Shakira
concert in the in the city or there was
a hurricane or there was you know just
some sort of festival it's not possible
for me for me to isolate the effect of
my intervention without having a control
group so that's not going to work
another thing we could do is what's
called the switch back and in this case
we have our same experiment and our
sorry we have our same city and we
switch between treatment and control
back and forth back and forth over
different time intervals and we do this
a doober for things like algorithm
changes because it allows you to not be
exposed to sort of inter temporal
effects in different cities because
you're still in the same city but all
users are being treated one way or the
other the difficulty here is if this is
something that is user facing then I
can't really switch them in between
treatment control so if if I'm treatment
and then I see the cash indicator and
then ice I don't then I'm I would think
what is the credit card trip well
actually you're just in the control
group so that's not a valid thing for a
user facing test but it is something
that we can do for things that happen
silently like the algorithm which
matches riders and drivers they don't
know if they're using algorithm a B or C
but so that would actually be a nice
causal inference mechanism for us but
not here
so now Sam will talk about another one
so NYX talks about how excuse me if
we're rolling out at the city level as a
problem if you want to just compare
before and after the other source of
variation that we could use most
obviously would be to compare to other
cities now for comparing post-treatment
for example Sao Paulo to Rio
there's clearly a problem if we want to
say that any difference between those
two cities is attributable to the
treatment we've just rolled out the two
cities probably started at very
different baselines but could we combine
these two sources of variation so
variation of a time and variation across
cities so one approach that we could
take is if we want to know for example
the effects of rolling out telling
drivers about cash in South Paulo we
could look at the change from before and
after in Sao Paulo and compare that to
the change before and after in a similar
city or group of cities so for example
in Rio and if we make the assumption
that's in the absence of our treatment
so in the absence of telling drivers
about cash Sal Paulo would have followed
a similar trend to the trend that we see
in Rio then the difference in those
changes the difference in those
differences we can call our estimate of
the causal effect of the of the
intervention and this is a very common
method in economics it's been used for
decades and if you buy that trend by
that assumption sorry of common trends
in the two cities that you're looking at
it's a pretty good way to go
the difficulty is that often that common
trend assumption may not hold you may
not know if it holds and this takes us
to synthetic control so we do a little
bit differently here is rather than
comparing one city to another and
assuming that they follow a common trend
we explicitly try and model what we
think would have happened in San Paulo
if we had not rolled out telling drivers
about cash so what does that look like
well I think this plot illustrates it
quite well so here in the yellow shaded
area this is before we rolled out
telling people about cash in Sao Paulo
the dates are imaginary that's not
actually when we did this and the blue
area is after we rolled out cash in Sao
Paulo and the dark blue line shows the
metric that we're looking at
for Sao Paulo over that period the
dotted line on the other hand is our
prediction for what we think would
happen in Sao Paulo in this period if we
hadn't rolled out the treatment so you
can see in this initial training period
in the yellow period where we actually
know what happens it follows the blue
line fairly closely as you would hope
afterwards the two lines separate and
the difference between those two that's
our estimate of the effect of treatment
on any given day so now to dig into a
little bit more detail what we're doing
here we need to understand okay how are
we going to actually predict this dotted
line I'm now we're a little bit
restricted in what we can talk about
here I should say just to sort of frame
this I'll talk about the approach we
take a duper at kind of a high level I
think it's fairly similar to approaches
that other people are using um but this
is sort of specific to the approach that
we're taking so in terms of the model a
number of things go into this that is go
into our prediction of this dotted line
at the outcome that we care about in Sao
Paulo so the first is data from control
cities so for example we might compare
cell Paulo to Rio sit down see I'll go
to Lima and take some sort of
combination of those cities outcomes and
making our prediction for são Paulo we
can also look at what's happened
previously in Sao Paulo and in those
other cities in making this prediction
and we can look at a control variables
that you might typically think of so
sort of weather would be a good example
for us holidays is another thing we
might care about in making our
prediction of in this case cash trips
per driver in Sao Paulo and now so what
does that look like in terms of a model
well what we're trying to predict here
is our outcome of interest in Sao Paulo
special cash trips for a driver and
that's going to be a function of cash
trips per driver in our different wall
in our different control cities so for
example Rio San Francisco and Lima it's
also going to depend on what happened in
the previous period in Sao Paulo and
it's going to depend on these control
variables or Cove areas that we've also
been talking about in the model and
there's a time series component to it as
well but we won't dive into that in
detail here and so we fit this model on
data from our training period so that's
the pre treatment period
get covariates for each of these factors
so very crudely put like how much which
we put on each of these factors in
making our prediction how do we actually
go about fitting that model well the
approach that we take is essentially to
fit a loss function so without going
into details about sort of that specific
loss function we're basically trying to
minimize the difference between our
prediction for the outcome in Sao Paulo
and the outcome that we actually observe
in Sao Paulo in that pretreatment period
then what does that mean for our actual
estimate of the treatment effects well
here we look in the blue period on the
plots earlier so after treatment and our
estimate of the effect on any given day
or at any given sort of period that
we're looking at will be the difference
between what we actually observe in Sao
Paulo and what we predicted from our
model in Sao Paulo so that's taking all
those features that we talked about and
the covariance that we fitted from the
pretreatment period very often when we
talk about the effect of an intervention
and when we're communicating that to
stakeholders we're not going to want to
communicate the different effect that
you see on on any particular day we're
going to want to talk about an average
treatment effect as you typically would
in in an a/b test and in that case you
can just average across the different
periods that you're looking at so if
we're predicting at the day level you
can average across different days in
some cases we're not able to do an a/b
test and we don't have enough cities to
randomize at the city level but we may
have the resources to roll out to more
than one city and in that case when we
want to get our average treatment effect
we average across the periods and we
also average across the different cities
to which we've fitted this model for so
that's a high-level overview of how the
model works and now Nick is going to
talk about how the model actually
performs and how its implemented in
practice Thanks so the main question is
does this work because remember I told
you I'm going to compare what actually
happened to my estimate of what would
have happened and the difference for
those two I'm going to say that is my
causal effect so that is only valid if I
can reasonably project that right and
one metric we can use there is to see
the overlap between the projection and
the actual in the pre period of course
we don't want over in the pre period but
this is kind of a good heuristic so
actually it works pretty well
we've been able to fit some pretty
regular time series using using this
approach so this is uber scale so we
have to do this a lot we have a lot of
users we have a lot of cities so we have
a spark infrastructure that allows us to
select hyper parameters that we're we're
it allows you to define initial hyper
parameters initial cities and then we're
able to spin through a ton of models so
that we can optimize this because as Sam
said we have to figure out our ideal
weights here we have to think of which
control cities we might have and what is
the best the best sort of synthetic
control that we can that we can come up
with trying to keep this in high-level
terms again and so yeah our our back-end
systems are actually able to do this
pretty efficiently which allows this to
be an actual thing that we can use at
scale so let's talk about other use
cases we can have an uber for using
synthetic control those who come from
driver surge ubereats uber pool we'll
just talk about two the first one is
let's talk about uber pool now the way
you were pool works is in cities where
there's enough drivers and riders it
tries to match riders that are going to
relatively similar destinations and they
pay substantially less but the algorithm
here is bouncing two parameters
essentially the first is savings to the
rider and the second is what you might
call the inconvenience which is how far
out of the way does the driver have to
go to pick up this other rider and to
drop them off maybe before after you so
of course everyone wants full savings
and no inconvenience but that doesn't
happen that's not the product but we
want to we want to tweak these things so
that we can have gains to all parties
including the drivers so one thing we
could try is if we can get oftentimes
riders are going to the same destination
like very similar or even the same like
the train station the movie theater some
event but they actually are being picked
up at different spots and that's where
the difficulty comes in so if we could
have rider be be on the way a writer a
we'd have like full cost savings and
almost no inconvenience so if we could
get writer B to walk a little bit we
could really generate some good and
marketplace efficiencies here and so
that was a pilot we tried we talked
about synthetic control and we talked
about another thing we could do which is
switch backs mister you might recall
with algorithms now that's fine if the
algorithm is silent if they're not aware
but if this is both an algorithm and a
UX feature like telling you to walk then
that's something that you can't do a
switchback for I can't turn that off off
and on for the same user so in that case
we'd want to use this instead of control
if we work here to try to model how well
this works and if we can actually pull
this off another thing we can talk about
here is surge pricing now surge pricing
would also be a good candidate for for a
switchback experiment which is sometimes
more precise than a synthetic control
been decided control structure but if I
have surge pricing and I'm used to
seeing surge pricing at the same time
and I'm I've built that into my user
behavior then if there's if there's a
spillover effect and users might notice
that this switchback is occurring we
might also want to investigate synthetic
controller there's a lot of other cases
where even though they're algorithmic
changes we still might want to use
synthetic control instead of a
switchback framework so now it seems
going to talk about some potential
drawbacks to this approach so this
approach has been really helpful and we
do use it a lot but we've definitely in
the process found some issues that it's
really important to be aware of when
you're going to use synthetic control in
the kind of context that we use it so I
think a first thing to be aware of is
that when you're just rolling out to one
city because Audrina shocks can still
invalidate your results and there's not
a great deal that you can do to fix that
other than avoiding these shocks in the
first place
and so it's quite interesting when you
think of an organization or level at a
company like uber you've got Ops teams
on the ground you've got multiple other
product teams you've got marketing teams
if any of those people roll something
out in the same city or the same country
that you're looking at at the same time
it's going to be essentially impossible
for you to do
in Tangled that from the thing that
you're actually interested in and so an
organizational level you have to think
about it quite differently from if
you're just have multiple different
teams rolling out different a/b tests at
the same time a second issue to be aware
of is that what we've found is that it's
difficult to detect small effects so if
we're rolling out a dramatic change to a
product such as telling drivers about
cash or cash in the first place this is
a useful method if we're thinking about
optimizing existing pages to marginally
improve conversion for example your
chances of picking that up in a
synthetic control design are really
quite small so wouldn't be appropriate
in that case so you have to be quite
cognizant to apply this another
potential drawback to be aware of is
that because you're looking at
everything aggregated to the city level
you're not well-placed to examine
heterogeneous effects among different
users and in some contexts in some
experiments that could be really key so
that's another sort of advantage of a/b
tests when you have the chance to use
them and I think a final concern that I
highlight and this applies to some
extent to experimentation as well but I
think the dangers are worse here is that
if you don't have some strict
pre-registration if you don't say very
clearly beforehand exactly how you're
going to do your synthetic control
analysis there's a very real danger of
you essentially manipulating results or
picking results until you get something
that looks reasonable now I would hope
that this wouldn't be sort of deliberate
but I think it can happen also by
accident in it you know if you run your
synthetic control experiment if you if
you consider a synthetic control design
you get results that look very strange
the chances are you'll dig back in and
say okay what did I do wrong do I need
to select different cities and so on if
you roll it out and things look okay it
looks reasonable it looks like what you
expected you are less likely to do that
so just through basically trying to do
good work there's a danger that if
you're not very very strict beforehand
about how you're going to do this you're
going to end up consistently producing
results that you can't really trust so I
think those are the four areas we'd flag
up from our own experiences where you
have to be very very careful about how
you do this
in terms of the key takeaways from this
talk we find frequently the a/b testing
is impossible particularly in a
marketplace setting and in that case
there's the number of possible
alternatives of which synthetic control
is often a really good option it
generally performs well and we've found
a lot of really good use cases for it
Aruba but as with all methods you do
have to be careful because there are
some potential risks so thanks very much
for your time and we'd be really glad to
take any questions you may have
[Applause]